[Music]
oh
faster faster can you make a little
faster grandpa well we can try
but remember we've got to slow down on
the curves
can you make it go still faster still
faster
oh dear
fast
faster the young just have to go fast
don't they
i should understand that after what
happened
how many years ago was it
40
43 i guess
when i was 21 i was ready to take the
measure of the world i was working on a
surveying crew during my vacation from
state college
it was hard work but i was in a hurry to
get ahead the opportunities made me want
to stay on rather than go back to
architectural school in the fall
and then another thing
there was
jennifer
[Music]
she had tried as well as she could to
persuade me to finish school
but one day i asked jenny to marry me i
said that i'd work hard i promised we'd
be happy together
[Music]
did i keep that promise i think i did we
decided quickly and it wasn't a mistake
[Music]
i worked up to the job of field
superintendent with the company
i remember my first day in charge of the
crew old man mcgovern saying we'll never
bring the job in on time
we did
[Music]
the next year we had a son
junior looked
i guess all babies look that way
i certainly remember 1917 at 18 as an
army engineer i had another job that had
to be done quickly
then
i returned to jenny and our son
we were all together again
[Music]
i worked hard i spared no effort least
of all my own
time became a challenge to me again and
again i won out over time and finished
jobs ahead of schedule
[Music]
may 14
was a day that ended like any other work
day
not an important date on the calendar
but an important one to me and my family
[Music]
so
jim are you getting ready
[Music]
jim did you hear me
just feeling tired
very tired
you've been coming home tired for months
now
are you sick kim
i'll be all right
in just a couple minutes
i'm getting a doctor
i was wrong it wasn't a matter of
minutes the doctor said i'd be all right
in about a year
there was no doubt about it
after all the medical tests were made he
said i had tuberculosis
i had to remain in the hospital for
treatment for rest complete rest for
about a year
the first six months to be spent on my
back in this room
resting wasting time
[Music]
at night it was even worse i worried
about my family how would they manage
without me i felt completely helpless
slowly too slowly it seemed to me i
began to feel better
the weeks and months passed then it was
spring when i went down for my periodic
checkup the doctor showed me that the
area of disease was now quite small
i felt as strong as i'd ever felt why
couldn't i be discharged now and go back
to work
the doctor said that the disease was
still dangerous and that it was out of
the question for me to leave now then he
told me that i had to give up the idea
of ever going back to my old job once
and for all
[Music]
that was a tough blow
he tried to soften it by letting me go
home to visit for a few days
every moment of my freedom was precious
i didn't even stop to call jenny i
wanted to surprise her wanted to see her
face when i walked into our home
[Music]
[Music]
the surprise turned out to be on me
jenny had been working
that meant little jimmy rushed off to
school in the morning not seeing his
mother until evening it wasn't fair to
the boy nor to jenny either
not so long as i was able to do a day's
work myself
i had to make up for lost time there was
a job to be done and i'd been hired to
do it
however it was work for a healthy man
and whether i admitted it or not i was
weak and still sick
[Music]
[Music]
once again i was in the hospital i'd
tried to hurry i'd gone too fast
now the prescription was at least
another year
maybe longer
for days i felt terribly alone and
depressed
neither the friendly old man who was my
new roommate nor the nurses could
penetrate the curtain of my helplessness
yet it was my roommate pop who finally
made me realize that i must forget the
past and start over with a new life
pop loved to grow things
one day in talking about his plants i
think pop was really trying to tell me
something plants certainly do good here
this pagodium my sister scent is
gloomy already well maybe this is a fine
place for plants but not for me
i can't just lie here
they say it's a year
suppose it's more
right one for wasting time
it's all just a question of getting
started
what do you mean
say
looks like this thing's ruined
took its own time all right
some decide to root fast and some decide
to root slow
some just can't make up their minds
it's all according to nature
i began to understand what he meant i
realized that i too had to grow again
i had to start a second life
and i had help for my doctor was all
things in one surgeon counselor and
friend he took me back to my college
days to my three years of architectural
courses
now they suddenly offered the prospect
of a new life i had found something to
start with something to build on
soon i was well enough to listen to some
sharp criticism the doctor imitated the
way i used to walk and then he gave me
some sound advice i've never forgotten
his words slow down to normal
slow down to normal
this became the key to my new life when
i left the hospital september 19
1927. i found a job in a busy
architect's office it was a big step
forward and i brought along a whole set
of new attitudes including patients
at least one of my co-workers didn't
seem to understand that i was completely
safe to be near
like a number of people he didn't
realize that your doctor won't let you
go back to work if you're liable to
spread tb
of course the doctor watched my progress
closely
in the evenings jimmy and i would do our
studying together
when i took the state licensing exam for
an architect's license i really had to
pass two tests
in the middle of the exam an old habit
came down
i found myself working faster hurrying
in order to finish ahead of schedule
a moment later i caught myself
what's your hurry wilson i asked you've
got plenty of time
slow down to normal
[Music]
i am proud very proud of that piece of
parchment
in the next few years i designed all
types of buildings little and big
[Music]
in 1939 my son jim got his license and
came into the office as a junior partner
when jim returned from the service in
1945 he began to take on most of the
work that i couldn't put in a full day
myself
regular checkups by the doctors proved
that my health was good but now i could
afford to take things easier
then one morning in 1950 we got an
invitation to submit a design for an
exciting project
jim realized how much it would mean to
me to design a tv wing for the new
hospital
when do you get started he asked
immediately i told him
but i suppose in a way i got started the
day i left the hospital 23 years ago now
i'd finish it
when the job was finally completed it
turned out to be the most modern
tuberculosis hospital in our part of the
country
it had operating rooms that reflected
the latest achievements in medical
science in the fight against
tuberculosis
here in the laboratory doctors and
technicians kept abreast of the latest
developments in anti-tb drugs here was
an up-to-date x-ray room with the latest
of equipment
in this modern tuberculosis hospital
patients had an opportunity to retain
old skills and learn new ones to start
their second lives
[Music]
i consider this the greatest achievement
of my life
so the day the hospital opened was the
day i retired from business
then there was only one name on the door
that of jim jr i didn't have to worry
about my son i knew he'd do a fine job
and besides i'd been promising jenny a
second honeymoon
we went back to niagara falls of course
but it was good to return to our
children and grandchildren to the quiet
excitement of peaceful surroundings
to the fullness and expectations of my
second
[Music]
all you have to do is get it back on the
track
and slow down to normal
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you